so what was the motivation to to do a
solo album
i've been trying you know i've been
honestly talking about doing it
for a long time but it just didn't make
any sense because i had two band i had
two great bands
um
i had you know i had opportunities to
kind of do
you know guest spots with a million
different people so that i was just like
you know what i just it just doesn't
make any sense to do a solo album right
now because i'm i basically get to do
any type of music i want
so right now just doesn't make any sense
the reason i did it now
was because i was i was putting
stone sour kind of on hiatus anyway
because i wanted to do something
even more different
and the whole reason i did the solo
album is because i had all of these
songs that i had written
that didn't work with either band
you know and i tried to actually give
these songs to other people and they
just it just didn't vibe with it or they
didn't want it or whatever and i just
said man these are [ __ ] great songs
i'm just gonna put it out myself you
know did you put it out yourself or did
you do it with warner
oh it's still on it's still on road
runner
oh [ __ ]
but the hardest name is corey taylor
we're still on we're still signed a road
runner so everything i do
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is it's completely multimedia
legitimately x-rated there's legal
waivers all over the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass so get to my
[ __ ] website stevo.com and get your
tickets man especially with this movie
coming out dude they're all gonna sell
dude so hurry up while you can get seats